قبل قليل هو بيان اليونيفل الذي صدر قبل
قليل تحدث عن ان الاوضاع الجديه اليوم في
جنوب لبنان
وطالب من جميع الاطراف اتخاذ الاجراءات
الذي
للوقاء على على حضرها تحدث عن ان هناك
مشاورات بين الجانبين اللبناني
والاسرائيلي عند عند الخط الازرق وكانت
ايضا قوات اليونيفل كات تدبير احترازي قد
طلبت من موظفيها التوجه الى الملاج ولكن
هذا لا يعني بان هناك خطوره هذا فقط تدبير
احترازي تتخذه اليونيفل في كل مره ايضا
كان هناك
بيان قد صدر الرئيس حزب القوات سمير جعجع
تساءل فيه عن دور الحكومه يعني
بعمليه ضبط الحدود وما هي مصلحه لبنان من
اطلاق هذا الكم من الصواريخ اليوم وسال
ايضا ان كان هناك زجاج واحد كسر في جنوب
لبنان فهل هناك امكانيه لاصل يتحدث
بالطبعا الازمه الاقتصاديه غير ذلك لم
يصدر اي تصريح رسمي ولم
يتمنى اي جهه حتى الان اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
علما ان اسماعيل هنيه كان في زياره الى
بيروت وصلها يوم امس وكان ايضا هناك
اجتماع مع امين عم حزب الله اليوم حسن نصر
الله البعض يعني كان هناك اقارن بين
اللقاء الذي جمعهما وبين الصواريخ التي
اطلقت من جنوب لبنان المنطقه التي اطلقت
منها الصواريخ بالطبع الجيش اللبناني كان
قد نفذ انتشار فيها ولكن حتى الان لم يصدر
اي بيان رسمي عن ايجاد منصه اطلاق اطلاق
الصواريخ
اهالي الجنوب تحدثوا عن ان هناك
عشرات الصواريخ التي اطلقت والتي تتمكنوا
من سماع صدى اطلاق صدى اطلاق صوتها
كان هناك طائرات استطلاع اسرائيليه فوق
كره جنوبيه
اطلاق الصواريخ كان هناك لغط حول موضوع
الرد المدفعي الاسرائيلي وهو ما نفاه
الجيش الاسرائيلي ولكن يبدو ان القبه
الحديديه عندما تعترض صواريخ تسقط هذه
الصواريخ ربما فيما اماكن مفتوحه في لبنان
هذا الامر فسره البعض بانه رد اسرائيلي
ولكنه لم يكن هناك اي رد اسرائيلي حتى
الان يبدو ان عمليات اطلاق الصواريخ توقفت
توقفت الان كان هناك
بحسب بعض المعلومات دفعتين من الصواريخ
التي اطلقت ولكن كما ذكرت اي بيان رسمي
للجيش اللبناني لم يصدر حتى هذه اللحظه